me voilà en plein coeur du parc naturel
de la brenne plus communément appelé le
pays aux mille étangs oui parce qu'il ya
aussi une technique de kung fu qui
s'appelle la technique de militants et
alexandra s'est lancé le défi en 2011 de
reprendre une ferme perrichon afin d'y
élever des cochons en plein air des
vaches aubrac et des chevaux d'ailleurs
elle propose des balades équestres afin
de faire découvrir cette nature
exceptionnelle dont elle est tombée
amoureuse
d'ailleurs moi aussi j'en train de
tomber amoureux de toute cette nature
les arbres
des fleurs found les tomates maïs aussi
les chevaux
j'ai moi aussi
ça va ça arrive à tout le monde ou bien
peu sont donc les bons repas quand les
gens vous connaissez tous longue et vous
voilà c'est bon c'est un auteur de le
faire mme alexandra salut oui il
s'appelle comment le cheval du goût
asian asian salut asian montana jolie
tête là un peu dans l'émission live et
une journée quotidienne d'alex à quoi ça
ressemble et les ya beaucoup de sauce
des contrées après coup il a atteint je
te suis allé mais partout
ça va bien ça me rappelle un clip que
j'ai tourné à marly gomont g20 tracteur
paris là où elle apparaît pas où on va
on coûte si c'est quoi la suite de la
visite là on passe derrière on va cochon
allez on y va direction les cochons les
métaux bis du mois escorté par deux
belles 2008 liste forcément la tâche au
delà soit là trickett
tu peux pas tricher en leur nom le porte
dans le reportage est accusée dans le
reportage bienvenue dame du bric est
volontaire là on va nourrir les cochons
en fait voilà ils mangent comme une fois
par jour une fois qu'une fois par jour
oui je intermittents les mecs on sait
qu'avec les abdos ils font attention à
leur ligne je vous regarde alors les y
allait les nourrir ah mais je croyais de
talent et y mettre un petit peu quand
c'est moi qui avais toujours quoi pas
pourquoi pas
un seul
clic est là pour toi et pour les cochons
autrement la cin la gent pitt ou
alors ah oui c'est tout montrait pas la
bonne méthode
quand même beaucoup plus efficace des
cochons j'arrive à la base c'était quand
même pour les cochons quoi mes briquets
calvaire plus sa vie
c'est bon on peut aller à l'est est
derrière maintenant
je suis submergé je suis submergé ans
coup
[Musique]
voilà écoutez je gère tout ça va aller
ça va les tuer je vais finir le boulot
que j'ai combien survint la manette
l'a25 surnage de lait québon là vous
fera chez le t-shirt avec la grille mais
c'est pas grave
laurence vous courage et merci
vous avez quand même super fernand moi
j'ai tourné un clip à l'époque la marly
gomont j'ai dû faire des allers-retours
dans tout le village si j'avais su je
serais venu tourner ici dans la ferme
soirée terrible et your way orphée wesp
essayé ouais on va refaire moi je refais
le crif c'est allez c'est parti tient
pas de la cité mais le but est donc ya
pas de paname et du bénin champions
n'ont pas de la cité et le pit est bon
japan armées du pays riches ont
franchement ça marche ça marche et les
zones et ça marche
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça ouais j'ai pas dit que je
ferais chevalin vous plus à alors un
dolce vita témoin sa malin et moi aussi
je veux du saut d'obstacles je vous y
sont toujours les malades affirme moi tu
sais le faire
[Musique]